[Musique]
la douleur et la colère de ces jeunes
motards
il n'aurait pas dû être là ici au
cimetière de sainte marie ils sont six
jeunes et pourtant ils doivent
accompagner leurs amis de seulement 19
ans à sa dernière demeure
ils sont aux côtés d'une mère à la fois
meurtrier digne et comme une ode à la
tristesse ils passeront airs passeront
en boucle cette chanson
benedetti mot graphique est renfort à
demi mot son les caprins c'est un bon
tour qui pâtit aveugle qui parti trop
tôt mais ou paca couperont les cafés
ball
autant
le monde ya six jours dylan a été tué
par balles à ducos deux individus lui en
prit la vie pour une moto juste pour une
moto mais meurtriers sont encore
activement recherché par les forces de
l'ordre
toute personne susceptible de fournir la
moindre information est priée de
contacter la section de recherches de la
gendarmerie au 05 96 57 09 31 dylan
aurait eu 20 ans